wir sind zurück im studio nena ein
politiker der also nicht als gutes
vorbild vorangeht und sich nicht impfen
lässt für dich vorbild hobbit mal
aufhören ich kann das gerade schon ich
glaube ich hätte an seiner stelle die er
entgegnet patricia woher wissen sie
überhaupt ob ich ein vorbild bin oder
nicht
also ich bürgerschaft zu machen hat
bisschen als politiker der sich findet
er zu stärken der vorbildfunktion an
sich haben ja furchtbar aufgeregt als
plötzlich jeder meinte auf instagram rom
protzen zu müssen mit seinem im kriegs
als nicht genug impfstoff da war aber
waren trotzen diese wir haben so auf
diesen impfstoff gewarnt mein gott war
ich vor diesen impfstoff zu bekommen als
meine frau diesen impfstoff das haben
wir darauf gewartet das ist doch also
ein damen wieder warum ist jemand für
euch kein vorbild der sagt ich will mich
nicht impfen lassen ich finde ich
ehrlich gesagt für mich hatte er gerade
auf vorbildfunktion der sehr klar zu
seiner meinung steht dass er vielleicht
vielleicht wird er zu dem punkt kommt
dass er sich impfen lassen will er ja
nicht gesagt ich hasse die impfung ich
bin generell ging es im keller zu dem
punkt kann ich sag ja auch warum der
filmfreund jetzt gerade zu dem punkt
gekommen ohne druck oder der sich auf
ihn eingeredet er wollte sie nicht
impfen lassen und jetzt nach ein paar
wochen ich habe gestern mit dem tüv
nicht als zehner ich war gehört heute
beim impfen habe abgekommen in der
sinneswandel
ja hätte sich jetzt lange damit
beschäftigt und jetzt hätte er sich
impfen lassen fand ich großartig so muss
es laufen und ich finde dieses lagert
ein vorbild oder kein vorbild ich kann
jetzt nicht sagen nur weil herr aiwanger
sich nicht impfen lassen will dass er
für mich kein vorbild ist ich kenne ihn
ja gar nicht ich finde wir müssen auch
wenn die menschen und indem wir sagen du
bist ein vorbild also philipp ist jetzt
ein vorbild er hat sich impfen lassen
und jemand der sich nicht impfen lässt
ist kein vorbild das ist für mich schon
völlig falsche diskussion findet also
was mir gerade zuge zugesagt da dieser
politische kampf der da eigentlich in
bayern gerade ist mit markus söder 1 1
man kann man sozusagen sagen und dann
eben nebenher anfang hatten wir gerade
gehört haben
platz teilt die bayern koalition
demnächst oder was ist da los also ich
glaube nicht dass die bayern koalition
platzen das ist natürlich dass ein
grundlegende unterschiede zwischen dem
ministerpräsidenten markus söder und
seinem stellvertreter hubert aiwanger
die da zu tage treten und auch zum thema
werde vorbild ist bis markus söder denn
ein vorbild wenn er sich auf dem berg
stellt mit einer maske als folge öfter
man ist er in ein vorbild wenn einem
leeren stadion steht mit fünf metern
abstand zu allen anderen oder auch eine
fb2 maske trägt
das ist eine hyper vorsicht die ich
überhaupt nicht vorbildlich finde ich
finde man muss sagen klar ist politiker
kann man sich impfen lassen dann schützt
man sich umgibt ein gutes vorbild ab
aber wenn man dann kerngesund und
geimpft ist und oft an der freien einer
frischen luft steht dann muss man sich
doch nicht mit abstand und fb2 maske
schützen das ist für mich auch kein
vorbild und ehrlich gesagt wenn unsere
politiker so tolle vorbilder während
beim impfen dann hätten die das vor
laufenden kameras gemacht sowie andere
premierminister und regierungschefs wo
war denn die bundeskanzlerin die jetzt
gesagt hat wir werben für den impfstoff
wobei sie denn als sie sich hat impfen
lassen ihr vertrauen millionen menschen
in deutschland niemand ist so
vertrauenswürdig wie die kanzlerin warum
hat sie sich nicht einfach vor laufenden
kameras impfen lassen
das hätte das wäre eine tolle
werbekampagne gewesen und nicht herrn
jauch zu plakatieren der sich noch gar
nicht hat impfen lassen
also bevor die regierung druck ausübt
wäre es vielleicht richtig wenn sie
einmal eine vernünftige impf
werbekampagne auf die beine stellt und
nicht jetzt den menschen droht das
funktioniert nicht das darf in einem
freiheitlichen land auch nicht
funktionieren
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dir hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren